scientists at the National Institutes of
Health are working to create a vaccine
for the new corona virus that originated
in China but they're not starting from
scratch they're employing an approach
called vaccine rapid response platforms
it involves high-tech methods that have
the potential to shave years off of
development time ideally they'd offer
protection while an epidemic was still
spreading instead of years later within
weeks of the world learning about the
Wuhan outbreak Chinese scientists
uploaded the novel coronaviruses genetic
sequence to a public database that
allowed teams around the world to start
designing a vaccine traditional methods
require an actual sample of the virus
typically scientists inactivate a virus
using special chemicals before it's put
into a vaccine when the inactivated or
weakened virus is injected into the body
the immune system recognizes it as a
foreign invader or an antigen vaccines
use antigens to prime the body to
protect against a particular virus but
vaccines developed with rapid response
platforms work differently rather than
directly injecting antigens into the
body these types of vaccines typically
send instructions to cells in the body
it gets the cells to produce antigen
proteins that are specific to the virus
it's designed to defeat these
instructions are in the form of RNA or
DNA the molecules that contain the code
for building proteins scientists say
this process cuts down on the
development time because they don't have
to grow the whole virus plus one
scientists identify and create the
instructions for one virus they can
tweak those instructions to make a
vaccine for a similar virus as a set
player and the new virus sequence of our
target like from the new corona virus
that sequence that we design and think
of it as a new cassette tape so you can
just slide it in you can slot in new
virus antigens
Melanie Savile is the director of
vaccine research and development at the
Coalition for epidemic preparedness
sepi is a global partnership that was
launched at Davos in 2017 we were
actually
and specifically to look at this type of
situation in this situation the
emergence of a new coronavirus seppies
funding several teams from around the
world that Savile says are each
independently working from the platform
model the sort of technology is that we
are looking at but some of which are
really quite pioneering can really move
very quickly three of the candidates are
in a category called nucleic acid
vaccines one of those candidates is
Madonna which is working with the NIH
they're developing a vaccine on a
platform that uses a part of the virus's
genetic code called messenger RNA or
mRNA so again unlike the conventional
approach with mRNA vaccine platforms
it's our own body cells rather than lab
techs that produce the antigen proteins
that are like the ones made by the
corona virus your immune system then
will be stimulated and develop
antibodies to the virus so that when you
see it again it can immediately
recognize the virus and prevent you from
becoming sick more and more people are
becoming sick from the novel coronavirus
as the race for a viable vaccine
continues public health officials don't
know how bad the situation will be by
the time they hope to have a vaccine
ready for widespread distribution
normally vaccines will take years to get
into the clinic so the sort of
technologies that we are looking at can
really move very quickly so an example
of that is getting from identifying the
sequence of the virus to developing the
vaccine doing all of the preclinical
testing manufacturing and getting into
the clinic in 16 weeks so around four
months during the 2003 SARS outbreak
that process took 20 months experts say
if one of the four teams seppius funding
is successful it would be a watershed
moment for human health these are very
promising candidates but you know
they're still quite early days